uh the u.s secretary of state is
addressing the un human rights council
let's listen him
as we meet
russia is carrying out a premeditated
unprovoked and unjustified attack on
ukraine
violating international law
flouting the core principles of
international peace and security
and creating a human rights and
humanitarian crisis
reports of russia's human rights abuses
and violations of international
humanitarian law are mounting by the
hour
russian strikes are hitting schools
hospitals
residential buildings
they're destroying critical
infrastructure which provides millions
of people across ukraine with drinking
water gas to keep them from freezing to
death and electricity
civilian buses cars even ambulances have
been shelled
russia is doing this every day
across ukraine the high commissioner
said yesterday that russia's attacks had
killed at least 100 civilians
including children
and wounded hundreds more
and said she expects the real figures
are much higher
and the casualties keep mounting
including the many civilians killed and
wounded in russia's monstrous rocket
strikes that hit an apartment complex in
park eve yesterday
russia's violence has driven over half a
million ukrainians from the country in
just a few days
children
the elderly
people with disabilities
who are making harrowing journeys
through conflict zones
if president putin succeeds in his
stated goal of toppling ukraine's
democratically elected government
the human rights and humanitarian crises
will only get worse
look at crimea where russia's occupation
has come with extrajudicial killings
enforced disappearances torture
arbitrary detention
the persecution of ethnic and religious
minorities
the brutal repression of dissent
the kremlin is also ramping up its
repression within russia where even
before the invasion it was shuttering
human rights organizations and harassing
poisoning and imprisoning
anti-corruption activists and political
opponents
authorities reportedly have detained
thousands of russians peacefully
protesting the invasions as well as
journalists covering the demonstrations
russian officials issued a warning to
the country's press that any reporting
that refers to the assault as quote an
attack an invasion or a declaration of
war end quote in other words that tells
the truth
will result in media outlets being
blocked and fined and russia's
prosecutor's office said that
any russian who assists a foreign
country
foreign organization or international
organization during its so-called
operation
may be imprisoned for up to 20 years
these are the human rights abuses this
council was created to stop
if we cannot come together now
when will we come together
we must send a resolute and unified
message that president putin should
unconditionally stop this unprovoked
attack as the secretary general and the
high commissioner have done
and immediately withdraw russian forces
from ukraine
we must condemn
firmly and unequivocally russia's
attempt to topple a democratically
elected government and its gross human
rights abuses and violations of
international humanitarian law
and we must take steps to hold the
perpetrators accountable
this council's decision to hold an
urgent debate on the crisis in ukraine
is an important step toward ensuring
documentation and accountability i thank
the many members who supported it
we must underscore russia's obligation
even in its unlawful invasion to respect
international humanitarian law
including as it relates to the
protection of civilians in the conflict
council members should stop using
language implying that all sides bear
equal responsibility for the unprovoked
attack of one side
this isn't even handed
it's wrong
and fails to place accountability where
it belongs
the same goes for members who argue
falsely that denouncing human rights
abuses is politicizing the situation
it is failing to speak up about human
rights abuses that politicizes the
situation
we must reject russia's attempts to
falsely justify this attack
as a defense of human rights
misappropriating terms that we reserve
for the worst atrocities and
disrespecting every victim of those
crimes
finally
we must press the kremlin to respect the
human rights of all russians
including the right of citizens to
peacefully express dissent
and journalists to report the news
and provide information to the families
of russian soldiers who deserve to know
the fate of loved ones killed in
president putin's war of choice
one can reasonably ask whether a u.n
member state that tries to take over
another u.n member state
while committing horrific human rights
abuses and causing massive humanitarian
suffering
should be allowed to remain on this
council
even as we focus on the crisis in
ukraine
it's far from the only part of the world
where the council's attention is needed
in belarus the lucasian regime is
brutally repressing civil society and
the country's pro-democracy movement
using transnational repression to
silence critics abroad
and enabling russia's invasion of
ukraine
in recent days belarusian authorities
have detained hundreds of people
demonstrating peacefully against
russia's attack
in china the government continues to
commit genocide and crimes against
humanity and xinjiang against
predominantly muslim uighurs and other
minority groups
we urge the high commissioner to release
without delay her report on the
situation there
we must redouble our efforts to address
the growing humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan
and press the taliban to respect the
rights of all afghans
including by stopping the unjust
detentions of women protesters and
journalists
ending reprisals
allowing all afghans to be educated and
to work in every sector
the human rights crisis in burma
cuba the dprk iran nicaragua south sudan
syria venezuela and yemen among others
also demand this council's ongoing
attention
in each of these places
we must not only denounce abuses
but work to stop them and hold
perpetrators accountable
yet at a moment when the world needs
both moral clarity and unity from this
council
some governments are arguing that
sovereignty gives countries the right to
do whatever they want within their
borders
it's no coincidence that many of the
governments making this argument are
systematically abusing human rights
and have been eerily silent in the face
of russia's flagrant assault on
ukraine's sovereignty
the universal declaration on human
rights begins with the word universal
because nations decided that there are
certain rights that every person
everywhere is entitled to enjoy
members of this council have a special
responsibility to strengthen
not weaken those rights
one way to do that is by welcoming
scrutiny of our own records
in september
the united states issued a formal
standing invitation to all u.n experts
who report and advise on thematic human
rights issues
we urge every council member to take
this step we know we have work to do to
advance human rights at home
every member does
what matters is that we all hold
ourselves to the same standards
and work to address our shortcomings as
we are doing
here's what else you can expect in the
united states on this council
first
we're committed to working with other
countries
including those we don't always agree
with
to advance human rights as members have
seen in their engagements with our
permanent representatives at the u.n in
geneva ambassador sheba crocker and our
new ambassador to the human rights
council michelle taylor
second
we've heard repeatedly that the united
states is often focused more on
strengthening civil and political rights
than we have on strengthening economic
social and cultural rights
people around the world are looking to
us to do both
and we hear that call
third
we'll continue to counter anti-israel
bias and the unfair and disproportionate
focus on israel on the council
the commission of inquiry and standing
agenda item 7 are a stain on the
council's credibility
we strongly reject them
fourth
we'll keep fighting for the human rights
of lgbtqi plus people people with
disabilities
members of racial ethnic and religious
minorities women and girls
and all marginalized populations and
people in vulnerable situations
in recent days
people on every continent have come out
to demonstrate against russia's invasion
and for the rights of ukrainians
they understand that if we allow the
rules of the international order to be
flagrantly trampled anywhere
we weaken them everywhere
as an estonian student protester put it
if ukraine is not a country
then president putin can say estonia is
not a country either
we stand for these rules not in
opposition to any government
but rather because we see our shared
interest in striving for a world where
all people of all nations enjoy human
rights and peace and security
and because history has shown us the
darkness and suffering that comes when
these rules are abandoned
people in ukraine and around the world
are looking to us
to stand up
and stand together
we must not let them down